H me no hiding I'm not
hiding I just have
food I'm just trying to get him to call
my friend okay what's your name
Valentina you got your
ID can I get in my
purse can you tell p to come pick me
up you can
wait where are you
going
because somebody just tried me and they
shot their gun and they're trying to
blame me for what they did who is this
person that's my purse hold
up a lot of money in my purse I'm not
I'm not going to take your money you
have any warrant to search me or
anything this is my purse I don't have
anything on my purse so we're inves
right
yes I've been here drinking I'm here
drinking I'm drunk but there's nothing
in my purse and you guys have no warrant
to search me or nothing so I'm just
confused on what the back
99117 there's nothing in my purse
obviously who the called you ising lying
what the I'm not even driving if you
even try to get me for a DUI I'm not
driving that's not even what we're here
for that that is a security guy he was
just telling me to calm down and tell me
he was telling me what happened outside
what happened outside what happened
outside was some girl shot her gun and
told me to get away from her okay after
I was just to my best friend my best
friend left me okay she left me because
of a fucking gunshot so uh who who shot
the gun I don't know who shot the gun
you didn't see her there was four people
there was four individuals outside
smoking cigarettes or whatever the they
were smoking okay and I was just trying
to get out and get out the way and she
got in my face I she was I don't I just
remember she had locks I didn't look at
what the she was wearing cuz I don't
give a about n that shit was she tall
short she was about my height fat skinny
she was she was my height that's all I
remember she was my height she had locks
and that's all I remember okay all right
so did she shoot the gun at somebody she
shot the gun in the air in the air yes
okay did she know where that bullet's
going after she shot it I know what the
she thought where the the bullet was
going I don't know I'm just trying to go
home okay well we got I left I came back
in here I'm trying to get my I'm trying
to get myself together and he has my
phone okay hang tight you're not hang
tight back over oh my goodness ma'am
okay well pretty soon you're going to go
on handcuffs if you want to play this
game I just want to get my phone that's
all you want to do well right now you're
hanging tight with me okay I have to get
home I know you do we we'll figure that
out after
okay all you got a video or anything
quit walking off I don't I didn't do
anything wait a minute that's I'm saying
I didn't do anything there was a girl
outside trying to be some
funny just run it to Quick Terry first
yeah oh I mean I can see it I should
have never came tonight okay where's my
phone can you phone I don't think have
your phone why would I have your phone
do have my phone I don't know I don't
know who has your phone okay like I said
quit walking off unless you want to go
handcuff I'm going to go to the I'm give
one more chance and you're going to end
up in handcuffs and we're not going to
go any further all righty can I talk to
my not right now not right now all right
if you want to keep playing this game
you're going to keep playing this game
then we're going to play that didn't do
shit we got to figure that out okay can
I go over not right now no you cannot no
all
right so where were yall when the whole
thing started I don't know I was outside
trying to get to my best friend's car
right in front I was trying to get to my
best friend's car and then some girl got
in front of us and she was forcing my
best friend to get in her car what's
your best friend were she's wearing a
white with black and um a orange okay I
know exactly where your friend is I know
exactly where your friend is sorry so
why am I getting in trouble for it right
now you're not in trouble like I said
we're just trying to investigate what
happened do anything okay I was just
trying to get to my friend's car and you
have my wallet okay so like I said we're
investigating all right we got somebody
called us said you were the one that
discharge a firearm okay so what we're
going to do we're going to do real quick
cuz we're going to pat you down and make
sure you don't have any weapons on you
okay you don't you don't have no right
to SM me down you guys are you guys do
not play this game with us yes I have a
okay calm down
okayu you don't have to do this in the
locker room okay and you have to
cooperate calm down all right all right
listen listen there is no reason for you
guys to search me like what the is going
on you're putting me in handcuffs for no
reason what am
I you know what I'm not even to
titer I have a gun on me I have weed on
me I have my jacket on me I have on me
it's on me okay where that's what I'm
asking don't go reaching for it okay
calm down where is I said don't go
reaching for it I didn't evening do
anything like what is the
problem like what the I didn't even do
anything
it's God bro like I didn't not even
shoot anything where is your gun it's on
me it's right here look listen
down in the middle part and it's right
there but I didn't shoot shit okay like
my oh my God this is crazy bro couldn't
agree more I told you I have weed on me
I have shit on me but I did not shoot no
gun
huh yep I didn't shoot no gun all right
where is your gun it's up front right
there
yes reach for it but I didn't fucking do
shit what the did I
do here it's all I'm asking you for what
did I do right now we got to figure it
out I didn't do shit I didn't assault
nobody I didn't do shit I've been inside
drinking let's check her out that's all
I've been doing let's take her out or at
least go in there with
her and you're over here recording me
Bailey
like for your I didn't do
anything why are you recording me stop
recording me bro the I didn't do
anything can you get my purse please I
got everything you need let's go like I
didn't do
shit this shit is fuck crazy
pulling I'm pulling cuz I want to get to
the jail
already fuck get me out of shit stop
ping no because I didn't do shit and
this is unnecessary you're making it
unnecessary no you're making it
unnecessary I didn't do shit the
fuck that's funny bro you're about to
break my wrist let go let go I didn't do
shit what
the you haters bro put her in my car
[Applause]
I have a question yes ma'am I have a
question yes ma'am when I get to the
jail can I make a call yep I'll let you
do that when you get to the jail why am
I getting arrested you get your leg in
the car can you please tell me why
you're you're not you're not even under
arrest yet get in the car get in the car
why am my handcuff get in the car can
you tell me why I'm a handcuff okay we
want to thank Morgan and Morgan for
sponsor during this body cam video I
mean I think it's pretty clear from the
body cams that we covered that it's not
always safe out there when you're hurt
it can be confusing it could be scary
you don't really know where to turn well
Morgan and Morgan is actually the
largest injury law firm in America and
in a time when you already have so much
to think about they're going to make it
super easy for you they have completely
modernized the process because you
submit your claim you sign contracts you
upload documents you talk to your whole
legal Team all on your phone that's it
it an attorney is going to review your
case in just eight clicks also they have
4,000 support staff that can help you
too which is just amazing to think about
and in terms of price well you only pay
them if you win there's no upfront fee
so if you're injured and you want to
join the over 3 million people that call
them every year you can submit a claim
at www. forthepeople.com
LC bodycam or by dialing pound law
that's pound 529 on your phone can you
tell me why I'm in ANS I didn't do
anything get in the car get in the car
I'm not getting in the car when nobody
telling me what I did get in the car
Daddy I didn't do anything get in car
get in the car I didn't do anything get
in the car get in the car no I'm not
getting in the car unless you tell me
what I
did what the did I
do what did I do you weren't under tell
me what I did
[Music]
no no what the did I
do I didn't now she's going to jail got
a clip missing fa when you I got her
hair everywhere
now sry
yep
yep I charge the firearm
too come think come back
clean
so
much showcasing I
got it's been
opened nope it's not I
don't yep same same con look at that
conduct foundy here
fire commiss you want
to call call back outside please anybody
know
went there's one in the chamber too
yeah is this
just charge with the you don't even know
what it is it a edible it's gummy weed
okay so it is an edible huh it is an
edible yeah
I go commissioner firearm she slipped
her
cops listen I didn't put my hand back in
a handcuff but I just want to know what
I did wrong can you please just tell me
what I did wrong you're going to let go
with the cup can you please tell me what
I did wrong officer officer you're going
to break your goddamn finger's go can
you please just tell me what I did wrong
I just want to know you're arresting me
because I need to know what the fuck I
did wrong I'm not resisting arrest I am
not
resisting I'm not resisting you're not
resisting but yet you won't let us go
put you in the fucking C stop it I just
want to know what I did
wrong I just want to
[Music]
know
please just tell me what I did
wrong
please I was in the
club what the
fuck wejust should I
do all right we're going to roll you on
your side kick your leg under you all
right we're going to stand you up hold
up hold up hold up hold up hold up hold
up what you want me to hold up for hold
up St up well I'm trying to pull you
hold up wait I can lift myself up give
me okay all right you're going to get
back in the car get in the car back get
in the car get in the car we're going to
p no you're going to get pulled again do
not play this game with us get in the
car get in the car I'm not playing this
game with you get in the car but can you
tell me what the f I did
wrong can you please tell
me did you get that firearm
secured you got your firearm secured or
uh this one I got
it
perfect I'm
going possession
of this possession of firearm
recognition of the felony this
conduct
and right here yeah I mean he found the
Showcase right
there
ID what is in here check
yeah
a little
there is this open or
[Applause]
not real or
not that that is dope
oh uh just hang Ty horse for right now I
got they got your name in the I think we
already yeah when you call 911 did you
give them your name and information
Compu okay perfect yeah we're good then
yeah I appreciate
[Music]
[Applause]
it find what so it was in a holster I've
never seen before it was like directly
in front of her crotch um I don't know
if it was an actual holster if it was
just like inside of her underwear or
what um
but yeah I uh I don't know I'd never
seen that before
so tell look at front because she the
other guy was like the front so yeah we
found a showcase right here so she's
going to be going to slew with
[Music]
things who
that's her
phone je he lose a
MAG I you didn't yeah
I a little bit weed this see it looks
open but it's not like you can't open
it you're all good appreciate
it right and like this hasn't been
breached either like the the
tear
so what I mean I don't think it's been
open maybe it
has just
weed
yeah there so with this packaging is it
still felony is that when it comes to
felony
huh
that's call Calvin
Smith at I got
regular do instruction we really I
don't want to
be
should thought about that
[Music]
before it was stuck in
my all I told was to get the away from
me what the
fuck God damn I what the
fuck is there a way I can make a phone
call when I get in there yep absolutely
what the what am I getting charged for
uh disorderly conduct possession of
marijuana discharge of a firearm within
500 ft of a highway or roadway wait
could you repeat and Reckless
conduct could you repeat
that uh possession of marijuana to
misdemeanor I told you that I had
marijuana on still legal to have and I
had less than a less than an ounce yep
yes I had less than an ounce yep firing
a firearm firing a firearm I did not
fire within 500 ft of a highway or
roadway I did not fire my
firearm is there any evidence of any of
that I did not fire my firearm I just
started to get away from me because I
was armed that's all I told her get away
away from me please stop talking to me
and she followed us up the road to my
friend's
car that's all I did I told her to get
away from me so how how am I getting
charged of that is what I want to know I
didn't do anything I did not threaten
her to kill her I didn't anything I
didn't not threaten her I didn't start
to get away from me and she
didn't and then she called the cops and
try to blame me I didn't even shoot my
firearm I just s it to back away from me
I'm I'm tixy just get away from me and
my best friend and that's it and she
didn't so I kept
walking it's not like I threaten her to
kill her like I will never kill anybody
the fuck who the fuck am I to kill
anybody I'm nobody to kill
somebody I will never harm or hurt
nobody body cuz that's not my place I'm
not God I'm not a motherfucking police
officer to just kill somebody like the
fuck I just came I'm from Atlanta I came
to Athens to come to the Christmas party
that I brought food to and then I was
chilling I was chilling I didn't do
anything I didn't threaten nobody I
didn't say anything to anybody I was
literally just in the corner
so I don't understand how I'm getting
charged with what did you say I'm
getting charged with attempt murder the
fuck I will never ever ever ever ever
ever ever in my 21 years of living try
to kill anybody cuz who the fuck am I to
kill somebody I'm nobody I'm just as
much as they are nobody to fucking shoot
my gun or try to threaten somebody like
that's fucking
pussy that's pussy if I was a murderer I
would have stood on it but I'm not a
fucking murderer I would never fucking
hurt
nobody and it's like why the fuck would
you take me to custody if I was just
there trying to tell her to leave us
alone I didn't shoot her I didn't
threaten her I didn't do
anything and it's like what the fuck am
I getting charged for
[Music]
nothing I'm getting charged for nothing
for being there because I have a gun on
me it's Georgia we all have guns on us
everybody in that Toppers Club had a gun
on
that literally I didn't do shit I don't
threaten nobody I don't start fights I
don't start nothing I just go in there
and mind my business
and wait for wait for the manager or
wait for the owner to talk to me like
what the fuck am I getting charged
for like I don't get
it like that shit is
crazy if I want her to do something I
would have did it but I didn't want to
do anything I just wanted to go I
brought mac and
cheese I brought
biscuits I brought all that to just lay
back have free drinks and have fun
that's all I
did and it's like you guys are arresting
me for no
reason like what the fuck is going on I
don't even know what I'm getting
arrested
for or why I'm getting
arrested I just know I'm getting
arrested because I have a gun on me
that's it but it's licensed me it's
licensed to Valerie Vieira
Flores and I didn't fucking do shit they
W I got my gun handed to me it was in my
coat out
6006 I don't even want to sit in
here like why do I even have to sit in
here didn't do anything I didn't murder
anyone rob anyone
drinking and having fun that's all I was
doing all I was doing was drinking and
having fun all I was
doing but literally I just showed up
from fucking Atlanta I just fuck I just
want to have some fun that's it I didn't
fucking do
shit and it's crazy how I'm getting
blamed for shit that I didn't even do
bro but you know what I'm Ready I'm
Ready 2 seconds you have all the time
you need okay please give me like two
seconds I have track in my hair so are
you going to take it out or do I have to
take it out you have what I have tracks
in my hair so that's what is I know I
know I just didn't understand you track
in my hair okay that's going to be up
for the jail staff okay I don't think
they're going to have you remove there I
don't want nobody to think that'll be a
violent but I'm like holding
my okay that's fine there nothing WR
with this why couldn't you have been
this calm the whole time I was trying I
was trying to explain myself I there
nothing do it this for I'm going to take
it I'm going to take it like a gr ass
woman I'm going to take it like a
do whatever happens happens I'm
ready I'm ready okay we got to wait on
that
Miss Forest okay I'm ready okay I got to
wait on them okay I got to wait I got to
wait on them
ready okay ready already miss fores can
I be honest with you yes okay you're
going to catch a bunch of misdemeanors
okay but you're probably going to be out
tomorrow that's this is just my dad was
in
jail this this
Cal down
[Music]
C okay you're
okay
okay okay
there do I need to take off my shoes
they will take off your shoes just but
you don't want to take them off right
now don't take them off right
now
C
down
[Applause]
C down C down to C
down
[Music]
f
you
step out of the way they got to come
out you're okay you don't got to
that I'm
okay they got to go out this door now
all right get right everybody DN right
right I my gun on that your here yeah it
would look it on me wouldn't
it I have a question yes
ma'am toward
there I got to go put my gun
up